John's with us in Chicago
hey John welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I got a question I have
been able to save up quite a bit a
decent stash of savings and the only
that I have is a mortgage I've always
been a avid investor and I was lucky
enough to get locked in at a low rate
about three and a quarter so just
curious your thoughts having a difficult
time convince myself to pay off more see
off my mortgage with such a low rate how
much do you owe on your mortgage
about 180 okay and how much is the non
retirement nest egg about 90 okay and so
you don't have enough to pay it off
correct so I've been trying to decide
does it make sense to just store that
chunk at that I gotcha
even though it doesn't pay it off okay
and the what's the home worse no 520
good okay and how much you have in
retirement 401 K about 150 IRA and Roth
of about 100 okay how old are you 35 oh
good you got a great start
what do you make of your household
income oh I'm going on just 140 well
great yeah you're in great shape you're
doing great man okay well here's what we
teach and then more importantly why we
teach it okay what we teach is a thing
called the baby steps where you're
debt-free everything but the house and
have an emergency fund that's one two
and three you've done that then we
suggest that baby step four that you
start investing in retirement fifteen
percent of your household income are you
doing that yeah so you got something you
got twenty twenty five thousand dollars
going into retirement accounts a year
two thousand bucks a month
yeah 10% in my 401k and then about
another 10% just goes into savings okay
but it's not going into retirement
well yeah member since going into the
fire okay that's your time so we suggest
um just trying to clarify where you were
on what we teach and then I'll go back
on to walk okay
so 15% of your income going into
retirement is what we would recommend
and so that would mean you would put 10%
your 401k and 5% more into Roth IRAs in
good mutual funds and in your 401k you
be in good mutual funds that's baby step
four five is kids college do you have
kids I do and you need to say for the
college right right
is there something independent of what
we've talked about that's covering that
that I don't know about 529 plans how
much is it knows about seventy five
between the two of them and they're how
old the kids five and eight okay so
you've got a really good start there
good so that's we can kind of check that
box and you just keep adding you've been
adding systematically to that it sounds
like and you keep doing that six is pay
off the house early so above 15% going
into retirement and above kids college
check we would say throw everything at
the house which is the $90,000 that's in
discussion here unless you don't have an
emergency fund if you do don't we do
some of the 90,000 for that and throw
the rest at the mortgage why would I do
that
okay and the reason is it's very simple
as we've studied millionaires over the
last 25 years and we just completed the
largest study of millionaires ever done
over 10,000 of them we find to start
with that somewhere in the neighborhood
79 percent inherited nothing and
somewhere in the neighborhood of 90
percent inherited not enough to make
them millionaires so 90 percent of
millionaires in other words are not
millionaires because of inherited money
but because of their habits and what
they do with their money and the two
primary things we see that those habits
that caused them to be successful
meaning hitting a million dollar net
worth and above is the primary initial
level
of wealth the first million or two
million is 401k and a paid for house now
the paid for house not only is going up
in value and stabilizers but we do not
find them saying I'm gonna borrow as
much three and a half percent money as I
can borrow because I can invest it and
make a better rate of return we do not
find them doing that we find them
getting the house paid off and using the
increased cash flow of not having a
house payment - then go bananas on their
investing and their 401ks and non 401k
investing starts to go through the roof
but if we fast forward your situation
like five to seven years and you're
sitting in this house by then it's worth
seven hundred and by then you'd have
five hundred in your 401ks probably
seven hundred in your 401k
you'd have about a million and a half
net worth million seven net worth of
which seven hundred thousand is your
house you would be typical in the case
study that we've done you'd be a typical
case study of the representative
statistically of the typical millionaire
if however you didn't pay off the house
you might still reach millionaire status
but you would be very unusual among that
group so the data points tell us that
the millionaires are paying off their
house now why would they do that because
of risk because 100 percent of
foreclosures occur on the house with a
mortgage and when you have zero mortgage
and you walk in the backyard and the
grass feels different under your feet
it's mine by God you know kind of thing
it changes the way you operate the rest
of your money
because you're standing on such a more
solid foundation to live your life you
don't you know you don't a lot of people
change jobs because they're no longer
worried about losing something they
we're in a job they hated just to pay
bills they they changed careers they
they take a little bit a more calculated
risk or something and we see their
incomes go up overall and so it's more
than just a three and a half percent
mortgage versus mutual funds return
there's risk in there there's life in
there there's stability in there and and
that's why we're seeing these
millionaires do that so all of that to
say
I would pull enough out of here 90,000
if you don't have a separate emergency
fund to fund an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
I throw the rest of it at that I would
adjust your saving by up five percent in
two so you got a total of fifteen going
into retirement five percent more going
into roth iras and good mutual funds I
think you kids colleges on track I keep
doing that throw the rest of it the
mortgage and then anything else you find
in your budget that you were saving
above that fifteen percent I thought if
that mortgage still that mortgage is
gone I think your mortgage will be gone
in about three years and you would never
borrow on a paid for home to invest and
so you wouldn't keep a mortgage a good
question thanks for letting me walk
through it with you